they've got a bunch of guys banged up
right now bryce harper on the il
gregorius roman quinn is out for the
year
this one shot out to right center robles
over and a nice lunging catch
victor robles drops it after he had
controls the grab
and they will give him the out there
great play by the national center
fielder ranging way to his left
[Applause]
look how far he runs for this baseball
this ball is in the gap 100 and he runs
it down
and definitely there's no question that
he caught it he just dropped it on the
transfer there
but an amazing play
and i can't wait to see the stat cats
and you see max is fired up knowing his
center fielder has his back
june 10th the park will be totally open
full capacity
lead off walk for trey turner here in
the fourth inning nationals have their
first base runner he's been banged up a
bit this season so he's not been as good
as he was in previous years but he's
been known for his pop time he gets rid
of the ball very quickly very strong arm
this season though maybe to your point
with the injuries has only caught two
runners attempting to steal
fastball to the left side
bone will go the long way and get
harrison at first turner moves into
scoring position with one out best case
scenario there moving trey over
so here's josh bell now with trey turner
still out there at second base and two
away now
as you can see them there at the bottom
left of your screen he is
staying right in trey's left hip pocket
pops this one to the left side will it
get down here comes mccutchen a sliding
attempt is no good trey turner will come
in
josh bell hustling the second and a
little bloop double the left field has
given the nationals a one-nothing lead
right off the knuckles here you can see
this ball beat him right off the label
it's a big strong dude
and mccutcheon is playing fairly deep
and this ball clearly drops in
but the best part about this josh bell
got on his horse and got to second base
so now the nationals have another runner
in scoring position
segura hits it sharply through the home
left side a base hit
police have their second hit
and for the second straight inning they
get the lead off hitter aboard
here's reece
what are the warning track is last time
segura goes pitch is taken for strike
throw to second is high and he is safe
at second base
what the heck is josh harrison doing
a great jump and a great pitch to go on
a breaking ball by scherzer and
yes
right leg kicked up in the air and hit
josh
right in the
right in the face
now that's something i've never seen
i'll tell you what you're lucky too with
sigour he didn't hurt his thumb
or even his the way he went in too john
yeah
his head look at this
bam
he stops himself from getting his
hitting his jaw on the turf
that one's pulls past the diving turner
into left center field
is going to score jt ties it up it's a
1-1 game
after a strikeout to keep from keeps a
girl from advancing to third base less
than two hours j-tune just hammers one
up the middle for a base hit and
sevora scores easily and now
keep your eye on j.t
bell the rbi double back in the fourth
starlin castro
a leadoff single in the fifth
and that's about it for the nats off
zach wheeler
a little trigger on that one this ball
is crushed to left field juan soto has
put the nationals on top in the sixth
[Applause]
absolutely crush this ball standing dead
into the eyes of zach wheeler
i mean this ball is destroyed
he stared at him a little bit run into
first he stared at him after he touched
home plate
i don't know if there was something that
happened in an earlier at-bat but juan
soto is fired up and so are his
teammates yeah i love it
so then that's got one in the top of the
fourth and the phillies quickly answered
in the bottom half we'll see if max can
host a zero here in the sixth
the 2-2
flipped out to right field soto coming
in makes a nice slide and catch
and he can do it on both sides of the
ball dan
oh yeah both in the infield and the
outfield good job by juan good break
nice smooth sliding catch
i feel like he just loves staring into
the phillies dugout or at the phil is
the opposing pitcher
wheeler though a struck out seven
yeah the o2 swag and a miss 96
make it eight eight strikeouts tonight
for zach wheeler
time to get this man some runs
see what max has for alec baum in this
kill count
fastball got him atop the zone
96 past him
eighth strikeout for max scherzer max
blown away the young phillies
right-hander
reaching back for a little bit more
no two-strike adjustment equals a punch
out
popped up
right side
josh bell
max scherzer's out of a jam in the
seventh inning
that hats will take a 2-1 lead to the
eighth in philadelphia
swinging a miss
max pulls out the change up ninth
strikeout of the game
well max do a couple change up to matt
joyce here in this at-bat and this is
the last one to get him for the
strikeout
excellent pitch
do they go fastball in do they go slide
her away
slider down below the zone and avila has
jankowski caught between second and
third
he runs right at him
still has the ball and that's a huge out
for the nationals and a huge base
running miscue
by the pinch runner
great heads up play by alex avila
and joe girardi is going to be answering
questions about this one for the rest of
the evening from the phillies
making sure he commits one way or the
other
got him hung up there popped up alertly
and go instead of giving the ball up
make sure you make sure the base runner
goes towards
one way second base or third base who's
such a good job by alex and that's a
long run for him to get the out
the 1-2
slider
popped into shallow center
victor robles says he has it and he does
the nationals have taken the first game
of this three-game series with the
phillies wat soto is fired up
and they have won this ball game 2-1